por con ella
[Música]
sí
increíble que no se puede creer o que es
muy difícil de creer queréis vivir algo
increíble
antes de comenzar laura ha repartido un
par de libros marta tenéis aquí conmigo
tenemos un fortísimo aplauso
permítenos
de presentar los libros el aleph de
borges y american gods de niell game and
dos libros que me han marcado el aleph
hace unos años y american gods hace muy
poquito no sé si has leído alguno no no
importa no importa no importa cual
utilizamos esté sujeta mente por fin
mira por ejemplo
si por ejemplo cómo te llamas
tú tú tú emma mira de marjorie pasando
así con el dedo y tú me paras donde
quieras o que gemma para mí hay página
453 vete la página 453 marta y cuando
llegues me avisas
en esta imagen no hay tanta no aparece
un poquito antes por fin
pajín a 105 vete a la página 105 x 105
tiene que haber porque me ha leído libro
ha llegado vale vas a leer siempre para
ti nunca en alto ok quiero que te vayas
a la primera línea y cuando llegas a la
primera línea de arriba del todo quiero
que leas la primera palabra la palabra
de la izquierda del todo pero para ti en
un alto látex y la primera del todo de
la primera línea la tienes vale bueno
quiero que grabes a fuego esa palabra en
tu mente para que sea más sencillo te
voy a pedir que imagines aquí un espacio
en blanco infinito sin horizonte y que
imagines sin hacer ningún gesto todas y
cada una de las letras en gigante que
forman parte de esa palabra no hagas
ningún gesto solamente imagina las
yo voy a utilizar algo que tengo por
aquí sabes lo que es esto
un hombre no es una pizarra del chino
que le he puesto el lector de mentes
está muy malito la cosa marta vamos a
intentarlo mira te voy a pedir marta sin
hacer ningún gesto que imagines que
trepa por la primera letra
salta la segunda
salta la tercera
mira hacia abajo es una verdad
sí
salta la siguiente
salta la siguiente es la última ya
verdad te puedes bajar
os acordáis lo que pasó dos libros en tu
poder
elegiste uno empaparon una página graba
esta fue una palabra en tu mente por la
cual fuiste saltando letra a letra yo ya
no toco puedes decir muy fuerte esa
palabra en alto drag drama y os acordáis
lo que yo dije al principio increíble
que no se puede creer
o que es muy difícil de creer
bienvenidos porque es un aplauso para
marca muchas gracias
para el ma por supuesto
[Aplausos]
buenos días a todos mi nombre es john
mayer soy mago abogado y miope lo de
y además voy a abogado es lo cuento
luego y lo de miope es porque soy el
único mago de toda españa que puede o se
atreve a hacer esto
mira qué ojitos chiquitico que tengo
ocho días esto es toda la vida
enganchado a la gameboy
hoy traigo para vosotros una confesión
ojo no vengo a dar lecciones a nadie de
hecho es muy probable que esté
completamente equivocado
me he equivocado tantas veces en mi vida
que no me extrañaría que ésta fuera una
más lo que tengo claro es que esta es mi
verdad y cuando uno cuenta su verdad
esta es auténtica y yo creo que llega al
que escucha espero que hoy mi verdad
errónea no llegue a vosotros
para alcanzar esa verdad hay que tocar
algo que está dentro de todos y cada uno
de vosotros así que damas y caballeros y
por primera vez entre decks os presento
al pollo interior
el pollo interior es la manifestación
física de aquello que quiero hacer pero
no me atrevo a hacer el pollo interior
nos conoce y por lo tanto no le podemos
engañar porque nos estaríamos engañando
a nosotros mismos entiendo que en este
momento estaréis preguntados bueno borja
y esta locura
como os conté al principio que yo era
mago y abogado pues bien un jueves
cualquiera después de una de mis
actuaciones estaba tumbado en la cama
con el sonido de los aplausos todavía en
la cabeza cuando me encontré con el
pollo interior me di cuenta de que yo
había nacido para estar conectado con la
magia yo no soy el mejor mago del mundo
tampoco quiero serlo
pero sentía como siento ahora mismo que
si yo tenía que hacer algún tipo de
contribución mínima al mundo tenía que
ser a través de la magia que yo podía
ser muy buen abogado no lo dudo pero que
nunca podría ser tan buen abogado como
mago
sospecho claro que en este momento os
preguntaréis bueno por esta movida desde
cuándo bueno desde siempre
de hecho permitidme que haga una pequeña
retrospectiva de pequeño me encantaba
disfrazarme de hecho valía cualquier
cosa he traído esta foto por un lado que
es para que sirva de ejemplo que no sé
de qué esté disfrazado y por otro porque
es algo muy rico y para que digáis eso
de
muy bien esa interacción buena desde
primera hora de la mañana
en segundo lugar desde que era
adolescente en el colegio en la eso en
el bachillerato me llamaban de todo yo
tenía un montón de apodos y yo sufría
mucho porque yo quería ser borja medina
y yo sentía que esos apodos me
despersonaliza van
desde siempre tuve muchísima miopía yo
de pequeño no veía la pizarra
yo tenía unas gafas doradas así de
grandes que parecía un médico de los
años 60 es verdad yo me costaba mucho
jugar al fútbol me cuesta muchísimo
bucear yo pensaba pero cómo voy a ligar
con estas gafas de culo de vaso que ojo
ligo no os preocupéis que no hay que
haya tensión ahora con 32 años me doy
cuenta de que mi pollo interior me ha
traído hasta aquí que yo tenía que ser
mago que yo tengo que ser mago que es
que no puedo ser otra cosa y os lo voy a
contar desde pequeño me encantaba
disfrazarme ahora me disfrazo pero ahora
me disfrazo de mago para utilizar la
magia como canal para fabricar
experiencias imposibles en la mente de
los espectadores o por lo menos así me
gusta entenderlo a mí
desde que era adolescente en el colegio
en la eso en el bachillerato me llamaban
de todo yo quería ser borja medina ahora
no me hace falta ser borja medina ahora
soy y quiero ser borja mayer desde
siempre tuve mucha miopía y la temía y
la rechazaba ahora lo primero que hago
cuando subo un escenario es decir hola
muy buenos días mi nombre es borja mayer
soy mago y miope lo de magos lo cuento
luego y lo de miopes porque soy el único
mago de toda españa' que puede o se
atreve a hacer esto y hago lo de los
ojos chiquiticos ahora la miopía es mi
carta de presentación 32 años después me
di cuenta de que mi pollo interior me ha
llevado exactamente hasta aquí hoy
cuando me ha levantado sabía notaba que
tenía que estar hoy aquí con vosotros
tenía que estar en esta charla te de c's
tenía que estar haciendo esta confesión
como quiero entenderla
pero sospecho que
preguntaréis bueno a ver borja mago
abogado que vino antes no esto es como
el huevo y la gallina que teniendo un
pollo de plástico encima de la mesa es
muy propio no pensarlo pero os cuento yo
elegir la carrera de derecho porque
quería ganar mucho dinero que ya os digo
que es mala idea de pensarlo así no el
tema es que yo no fui alumno prodigio ni
de broma pero según iba avanzando la
carrera yo le iba cogiendo el puntillo
al derecho eso sí mientras me sacaba por
ejemplo derecho civil 4 llegué a sexta
convocatoria así me echan de la facultad
en derecho romano no hay verano sin
derecho romano decimos o derecho
concursal 3 que os dará lo mismo pero
fue la última asignatura que me saque y
os prometo que tengo la tengo mucha
tierra pues mientras hacía eso iba
haciendo otras cosas por ejemplo monté
una web para dar visibilidad a grupos
indies de música fracasó
estrepitosamente lo cuento ya monté una
cosa que todavía no tengo mucho cariño
que es la cara oculta de la luna un
programa de radio de misterio al más
puro estilo iker jiménez que hacíamos en
un pueblecito de la sierra norte de
madrid en san agustín fm por lo que se
llama san agustín del guadalix sentía
parecía no que ese pollo interior de
alguna manera estaba ahí conmigo
claro que cuando empecé a dedicarme de
manera más profesional a la magia empecé
a plantearme casi desde un punto de
vista filosófico si yo era más mago que
abogado
para mí era sencillo la diferencia entre
estar en un teatro actuando delante de
la gente y al día siguiente ponerme una
corbata una chaqueta sentarme delante de
un ordenador a teclear para mí en virtud
de lo que yo sentía y de lo que yo
siento me dejaba muy claro que yo soy
más mago que abogado
pero un día
en el que me quedo clarísimo
estaba dentro del despacho de mi jefe él
me estaba echando la bronca por algo que
estoy seguro que tenía razón
y me dijo unas palabras
que estoy seguro de que él no recordara
no va a recordar ahora mismo y estoy
seguro que él no se imaginaba que me van
a marcar tanto
en mitad de la discusión
extendió su dedo índice hacia mí
me miro a los ojos y me dijo sabes una
cosa borja a lo mejor no vales para ser
abogado
os prometo que después de tantos años
estudiando la carrera
y otros tantos en aquella empresa que tu
jefe te diga que no vales para ser
abogado eso duele
pero lo curioso es que ese planteamiento
se ha transformado con el paso del
tiempo en una reflexión completamente
distinta una reflexión que me hago todas
las mañanas de verdad una reflexión que
me hago incluso antes de tomarme mi
primer café
por la mañana
me pregunto me planteo borja
quizás tu jefe tenía razón y tú no vales
para ser abogado
quizás tu jefe tenía razón porque tú
para lo que vales es para ser mago
y como soy mago quiero terminar haciendo
lo que más me gusta hacer en esta vida
magia desde el principio
una baraja
y un planteamiento y es que esta mañana
mi pollo interior me ha dicho algo y
quiero cotejar si es cierto tengo aquí
varios pollos de plástico que voy a
lanzarlo a tres de avanzados a tres de
vosotros y os vais a quedar e va a ser
mi regalo aparte de que todos os lleváis
ya ese pollo interior etéreo lo vais a
llevar para siempre tres de vosotros os
vais a llevar un pollo interior de
plástico físico así que voy a empezar
por ejemplo por este ladito de aquí lo
voy a tener
no duele este plástico para el primer
pollo por ahí hay una preparada
en esta baraja de dorso azul que tengo
aquí es una baraja de póker ok hay
cartas que son rojas y cartas que son
negras
emma con el pollo en la mano tú qué
sientes roja o negra
negra
segundo pollo por aquí por el por el
centro vamos allá el segundo proyectil
huelva
cogerlo
asustado claro ahora con dentro hemos
dicho negras dentro de las negras están
picas y tréboles con el pollo en la mano
que sientes picas o tréboles
tréboles
y queda el último pollo para allá a ver
si llego el que es not el gimnasio vamos
allá
nueva ha caído como una bomba el pollo
bueno bien bien bien bien bien
dijiste tréboles no dentro de las de
tréboles fíjate está a 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 y las figuras j
y rey con el pollo en la mano que
sientes
en la baraja un comodín que vale por
todas pero no es el caso vamos a buscar
el as de trébol es que tiene que estar
por aquí se resiste allí está
después de todas vuestras decisiones
negra tréboles el as es increíble
que todas las cartas
allí he elegido al final el as de
tréboles
pues queridos amigos dt de c's aunque no
lo creáis resulta que nuestro pollo
interior
lo sabía
muchísimas gracias
[Música]
i